hey martin did you see that live stream
from the nature reserve
hey katie yeah i'm watching it now it
looks like a django pony had wandered
into
unicorn territory geez i hope they get
along okay
here's hoping
alex is an engineer at vivid a digital
agency that creates websites for their
clients
using django django is a web framework
written in python that handles serving
web pages for you
you define data models as python objects
and django simplifies communicating
these to a database
vivid's client website like agit
construction
currently runs on servers in vivid's
office but the company is moving to the
cloud
alex looked at running their existing
client websites on virtual machines but
that would require a fair amount of ops
work
alex wonders can they go serverless
yeah they can cloudrun is a managed
serverless platform where each service
runs stateless
no data is stored on the service itself
but
cloudrun can connect to stateful backing
services databases apis and the like
web frameworks that rely on databases
like django can run in a serverless
setup with some configuration
the general steps described in this
video can be used for not only django
but
any other content management system that
uses django such as wagtail and django
cms
we've created code labs that walk you
through everything described in this
video they're linked in the description
below
any django site can be built into a
container image this image can be
deployed as a cloud run service
but that just handles the code part
django also needs a database to store
relational data
and a place to store media and static
assets these two
backing services need to be provisioned
and accessible by the service
first let's talk data django supports
many relational databases
including postgres and mysql alex can
use
cloud sql a managed database service
that supports both postgres and mysql
and even mssql when alex first deploys
their cloud run service they'll need to
set the add
sql instance parameter linking their
cloud run service with their cloud sql
database
this allows the servers in the database
to communicate over an automatically
encrypted connection
django will also need connection
settings not just
the instance hostname but also the
database username and password
alex can store these credentials using
secret manager retrieving them at
runtime
from here everything is set up to run
django's migrate command
secondly media and static assets
alex can configure their new django app
to use a google cloud
storage bucket to store these files
cloud storage can be configured as a
custom storage backend in django using
the django storages package
alex just needs to install the package
and edit their settings.pi to use this
new storage backend
and point to their new cloud storage
bucket from here everything is set up to
run django's collect static command
this all seems great but about those
django commands
where do you actually run those well
this is the question martin
cloud run focuses on serving containers
and doesn't provide a way to run a
one-off shell command against
a running service what alex can do is
run these commands as part of their
continuous integration process
using google cloud build in their cloud
build config they can add a new step
called migrate between their build step
and their deploy step this migrate step
uses the app
engine exec wrapper which allows
commands to be run against a database
during a cloud build job
additionally they can configure this job
to be automatically run anytime the
gate code is updated in source control
using cloud build triggers
if an automated process doesn't work for
alex's migration strategy
they can run their migration commands
manually with help from cloud sql proxy
we've described this method in more
detail in our blog post by connecting
these managers services together
alex is able to host their websites in
the cloud
these services automatically scale up
and down as their load changes
throughout the day
without having to pay a fixed price for
a virtual
server details for everything mentioned
in this video
including the code labs are linked in
the description
so how are the hood doing uh it looks
like they're getting along great
yay
[Music]